- Uh oh, look what we have here.
- Oh hey.
- On Faceook at work.
- It's just, my, uhhh,
my sister got engaged
and its all their engagement photos and --
- Yup, just exit out of there.
Oh, YouTube.
Watching funny videos at work too huh?
- Sometimes you need a break.
- Oh, Tumblr. You blog,
I didn't know that.
- I run a food blog.
- Okay, cupid.com.
- Oh boy.
- Eleven great vacation spots to go
to when you hate your job.
Google search:
I just ate six month old
cereal, is that okay?
Was Toy Story based off a true story.
Dope-treehouses.com.
Help, I just ate six month old cereal,
and now I don't feel good.
- I thought I was gonna to die.
- How-to-dress-like-prince.com.
- Halloween's coming up.
- Prince shirtless.
Is that for the costume?
- Mm-hmm.
A photoshopped picture
of me with Donald Trump hair.
A photoshopped picture of me kissing
the Queen of England,
and now a photoshopped picture
of you riding me like a pony.
Okay.
- I'm sorry sir.
It's just, we get kinda bored here.
- I don't wanna hear it, alright?
This was actually kind
of fun and entertaining.
- Okay, so we're good?
- Uh, your fired, but,
uh, that was a good time.
Thank you again Danielson.